الفلسفه هي نبته اجتماعيه وان كانت طبعا
انشغالا ذاتيا وتراهن على الذاتيه وعلى
الاستقلال والحريه لكنها هي ضمن هذا يعني
السياق الاجتماعي احد المؤرخين الفلسفه
يحاول ان يفسر ظهور لماذا تميز اليونان
بالفلسفه لماذا دائما يقال ان الفلسفه
بدات من او علق انهم قدموا وحده من افضل
النسخ في التاريخ الدولي بالضبط لان
بالضبط الدوله المدينه الدوله التي حققت
حققت شرط المدنيه شرط الامان وشرط
الاستقرار وشرط حتى الاستمتاع بالحياه
بالضبط كل الكلام كان على المائده نعم
فهذا هذا هذه هذا الاسترخاء الوجودي الذي
توفر هذه المدنيه في الدوله المستقره في
دوله الرفاه يعطي هذا يعطي الانسان وقتا
وفرصه للتفكير
للتفكير والتامل والمغامر